Monsieur le Commissaire chers collègues
chaque européen génère près de 189 kg de
déchets d'emballage par an un chiffre en
constante augmentation la gestion des
déchets touche à la préservation de
notre planète dans ce contexte le
Règlement sur les emballages est un pas
significatif vers la réduction des
déchets la révision de nos normes va
permettre de favoriser l'innovation dans
les matériaux d'emballage durable la
collecte le recyclage ainsi que la
réutilisation des emballages lorsqu'elle
est possible cependant la réussite de
ces initiatives dépend de l'engagement
actif de chaque citoyen et de chaque
territoire assurons-nous que les
citoyens s'approprie pleinement ces
nouvelles règles par ailleurs les
boissons spiritueuses de nos outremè
représentent l'excellence et le
savoir-faire de ces territoires elle
mérite une attention particulière en ce
qui concerne l'obligation de réemploi
des bouteilles je ne suis pas convaincu
que cette mesure soit adaptée à nos
régions
ultrapériphériques avec le vote de
demain nous pouvons trouver le juste
équilibre entre nos objectifs
environnementaux et l'adoption des
règles qui fonctionnent pour tous